[Music]
dear Tammy I know you're busy focusing
on acing that test or winning that next
track battle but I want you to take a
step back you achieve more than you ever
imagined and succeed beyond your wildest
dreams
but it won't be because you were smarter
stronger or faster than anyone else no
matter how hard you try and you will
tear yourself up inside trying you will
never achieve that 4.0 GPA and you'll
never be that high school track star
that you and your parents wanted you to
be but you'll learn that perfection
isn't what matters it's how you respond
to hardship and failure that defines you
you'll see it in your daddy's eyes when
his failure to prepare make tough
decisions or set his ego aside leads to
years of struggle for your family you'll
be hungry relying on food stamps to feed
yourselves you'll be nearly homeless
having lost almost everything that's
important to you but you'll see how your
family works to recover your family will
work harder than you've ever had to
before and harder than you will ever
have to again you'll come out tougher
but also more humble you'll learn that
gratitude is essential and you'll learn
how to survive a tough time which is
good because you're gonna need that
skill again
you would join the army and you will
have two very different lives
your first will be on a path towards a
happy life and happy family with
achievements in the military and a
chance to travel and see the world
but that wonderful life won't end so
abruptly it will feel like a death and
it'll put the rest of your plans for
your family or your career on life
support helicopter pilot lost both legs
when our National Guard unit was shot
down over Baghdad you almost died but
you'll make it
just barely your survival won't have
anything to do with your own abilities
you'll make it out alive completely
because of the grit sacrifice and
outright heroism of others you haven't
done anything to be worthy of their
sacrifices but these heroes will give
you a second chance at life anyway your
second life begins when you wake up a
few days later in agony non-stop
unrelenting seemingly endless agony the
pain is all-consuming that you even tell
the love of your life that you're gonna
shut down and be gone for a while to
quote circle the wagons he'll be
terrified because he thinks you're
saying goodbye forever but Yuri emerge
sure you'll be angry vengeful and scared
but most of all you will dig into the
deepest part of yourself and find a way
to survive it you realize how much you
owe those around you and come out
determined to never let them down and to
live every day to repay them you'll be
so grateful and proud not just of your
husband who becomes your champion
but all those who sacrifice to keep you
alive you have to learn to walk eat
bathe and do everything again by falling
crawling pulling yourself back up you'll
remember that you're a soldier and you
will never give up and you will never
abandon the mission and as an officer it
is your responsibility to take care of
your troops because of that mission
you'll meet a powerful man senator dick
durbin who instead of seeing someone
pitiful and broken in a wheelchair sees
you as someone who can help make gun
nation better who challenged you to once
again serve your nation but this time by
running for Congress you will be
apprehensive but you'll say yes and work
as hard as you can to succeed and you
will fail but this time instead of just
a personal failure like a bad grade or a
swing and a strike the world will know
that you'd failed but somehow it won't
be as devastating as it would have been
in your first life you'll pick yourself
up again because anything else would be
to betray those who sacrifice to save
you in that dusty field interrupt
you reach once again into that well of
gratitude to find a new way forward as
an advocate for your fellow veterans and
just a few years later you'll find
yourself in the best position you've
ever been in to repay those who
sacrifice to save you tonight we sent a
message that a positive campaign that is
focused on solutions for working
families and the challenges they face
can still be successful you'll be a
United States Senator people will start
recognizing you strangers will stop you
to say hello and thank you for your work
you'll see the difference that you can
make in people's lives your achievements
now can actually make your nation a more
perfect union service members get take
advantage of all the time and you'll be
proud of it all but as happy as you are
to be able to help people the best part
of your second life will be you finally
getting to have the family you've always
wanted senator tammy duckworth
oh my gosh we should point out that last
picture we just saw his big sister
Abigail there with mom and dad and we
want to wish them all the very best this
morning as her family has expanded what
amazing news and talk about a second
chance at life right and that never give
up I'm constantly never giving up and
now I love that idea of being able to
repay those who sacrificed and saved her
when she went down that chopper what a
mentor dick durbin was too interim and
you'll be able to read many letters
we've featured in our note to self
series in our first book note to self
inspiring words from inspiring people
will be available in May it will be
published by Simon & Schuster which is a
division of CBS